slams on the brakes to the back drive by
mark's battle four in front and taken
around behind by the caps and they work
the other way punch back out again and
return to camaro
leads one ahead
[Applause]
[Music]
i don't see any bad ice there
[Music]
outlook pass
in behind
john erskine is that a terrific game and
give it go
chamera to fair back to chimera and then
eric vargo's top shelf on marc-andre
fleury beautiful area pass up and over
the stick of paul martin
and the captain of the two-goal lead
just love that give it going the neutral
zone and johnny erskine with the tape to
tape to start it all off what a finish
by eric bear players that can wow
tribute even when he's not scoring and
the red wings almost turned over right
in front of their own net but back the
other way down to he splits the defense
he gets into the back and he scores
[Applause]
dangles from the blue line in and gives
detroit a 4-3 lead and enzo i'm telling
you right now he got a burst of wind
behind him that pushed him through the
defense
you watched this eddie we saw the filth
and draw a penalty by driving through
the wings defense watch the flow
there's always a quick burst
right here oh he just got in between the
blackhawk defenseman was able to go
forehand backhand
and the strength of datsuk
you'd be able to hit that acceleration
pier
as you mentioned and then have the
patience to hold on to it and move the
puck
laterally and throw it between the legs
of chris the ball you weigh not able to
cover the five hole with that stick up
in
lost his footing ryan schooner recovers
from boston
spooner angling one of the top of the
zone that's kept in and bachelet he's
got it down switch it over to the far
side for thomas mckenna cannons across
the ring pacharetti getting him on the
ball and that was knocked in out of the
air and it's brendan gallagher is back
from montreal he's giving the canadians
a three-nothing lead
[Music]
brian spooner had the puck low and he
tried to cross ice pass that he probably
shouldn't have done and then the
montreal canadiens get the puck and you
can see the lateral movement and a
little baseball play it's almost like
lacrosse with the puck's not even on the
ice is it comes from the corner out to
the front and gallagher is just gonna
bat this puck out of there you see patch
already takes it out of the air
on the pass to gallagher and then
gallagher takes it out of the air to bat
it into the net great hand-eye
coordination that's more of a lacrosse
play than a hockey play
slowly go to the bench in some pain
monsieur got the clear down to 15
seconds ago in the middle pretty
[Applause]
oh what a stop by the canadians that
minder mike condon with the save of the
day
absolutely we haven't said mike conan's
name and big saves in this game but this
is one that keeps the zero on the board
for the canadians ryan spooner gets it
just a little too much time which allows
condon to move over but give condon all
the credit in the world here he comes up
and he just throws the glove up and
takes that puck which was headed to the
top corner
richard along the boards the back pass
off the stick blues breakout three on
one
with johnerson back and the lead to tara
senko it deflects in
it went off the defender on the play
tereseko gets the goal and the blues
lead 2-1
great pass
laying it over to space
look at that puck go right off
[Applause]
[Applause]
that's that shot we're talking about the
thing that makes him so dangerous with
his release is you never know when it's
coming and when it comes it comes off
quick two goals here in the third for
planning paracento giving him 18 on the
season
danny briere on the ice of the time will
take him
in post-game shootouts he's 20 for 45.
anywhere close to 50 is tremendous grier
against lovequest
with
19.6 to go
mcgreer picks puck head up all the way
lung twists down tries to go between the
legs and the reaction from henrik
lundqvist
grier had his mind up
mine made up the whole way amazing story
all afternoon into this early evening
for the new york rangers still time for
the flyers big face-off here
[Applause]
green to ovechkin and back watched by
seabrook who blocked it ovechkin tried
to follow up
[Applause]
the quick pass from mike green now watch
what happens ovechkin breaks his stick
right there it gets slashed right out of
his hands by brandon's side and from
about 35 feet out the former blackhawk
troy brauer beats
corey crawford
i was just quick to department anything
else said he want a shot
what a great play
watch the area of the ice there's brower
right next to ovechkin
and maybe right there as ovechkin was
coming without a stick maybe at the last
second he moved out of the way
and brower is able to take that shot you
see crawford kind of leaning a little
bit but
that's one of those i think you gotta
stop
trips out of his hat here goes to the
backhand
and
scores
that's pretty
i don't know how you stop him when he
does that
he always seems to get it up on his back
hand up over top of the goaltender smith
comes out to challenge lukel scores
he shoots every time
he's got that tremendous release
and he'll always bring it in from left
to right and then just wire it
as the third shooter to try to break the
1-1 tie
[Applause]
and too much stick handling he almost
turned himself into the ice
and you watch the ice play tricks on him
now
too late
toronto wins it voldeck with the
shootout winner
and the maple leafs with a 3-2 victory
whiteman trying to cover work loose by
richards
unbelievable action in front of the
boston goal
lobbed on a head to chart 315 left and
sudden death
moves in in a two against two every
player standing at their bench areas
taking it as bergeron nicely able to
step away
wrong one in front of
the good play there by bergeron eluding
the check with a little bit of a pull-up
and then looking going hard to the net
marco sturm with a little bit of a
redirect after the terrific play there
by patrice bergeron mike richards loses
an edge bergeron gets it to the front
and the bruins win in extra innings here
at fenway park
the game on his stick right here
score
penguins win
right between the legs doc
snow flying in their faces as they
celebrate
the shootout winner by sidney crosby
goes between the legs of ryan miller
but as he was approaching ryan miller
you couldn't even see the puck
and then he made the quick little move
right between the legs and the penguins
win this game
miller against o'reilly
zuccarello has it along the boards
out to shatten kirk back to zuccarello
looking toward the net
out to shattenkirk
he shoots save letter rebound score
jt miller
with a power play goal
the rangers win it in overtime
three to two
kevin shattenkirk's gonna do what he
does best and that's get pucks through
to the net
it's gonna surprise robin leonard
he makes a beautiful save but not before
jt miller can jump on the rebound and
bury it and the new york rangers
find a way
watch kirk as you see him up top he's
looking he's waiting he's watching
he gets that puck through really had a
chance to score if leonard doesn't come
up with a huge save
he does he can't control the rebound jt
miller finds it
along behind and mikayla able to play it
back up the wing but this went all the
way to center mark andre fleury just
went off awkwardly in his crease after
that last clear out by the penguins look
out
right ahead is ovechkin oh and getting a
piece of it was flurry
another try behind for backstrom fed one
in front jammed out there by jay beagle
still they try another one by ovechkin
and that's held by fleury
ovechkin looks to the open sky here at
heinz field
here comes ovechkin
in front and he has to move that puck
because of the sliding play
by paul martin right there and fleury
what a quick left pad
that's some athleticism from everybody
involved but ovechkin you get an idea
that he's fighting it because enzo you
know he really likes to rip shots and
marc-andre fleury might be in his head
i
have to think it's got to be something
medically wrong absolutely
first national hockey league goal for
braden shen and the philadelphia players
have the lead in their outdoor classic
if you listen to the game plan of peter
lovely it's
get pucks to the net get traffic in
front and here's a great example of it a
simple looking play
watch carl as he gets to this loose puck
it's almost out just turns and fires and
the rebound glenn that's one i'm sure
henrik lundqvist would love to have back
and control a little bit better well you
can guarantee that braden shen's first
role was outdoors and his first nhl goal
now is outdoors
good point so nothing serious strikes me
as it might be
just because it's gone on this long
here's talbot across
[Applause]
odd man rush because michael delzado
gets caught up in the ice
[Applause]
what a pass by talbot forehand backhand
remember in the first period
the breakaway by claude giroud very
similar situation goes to the same move
but makes it a little bit earlier
and he goes upstairs too doesn't he
rather go along the ice get it up to the
upper part of the net handed it across
now to ovechkin moving back in along
with backstrom but a nice denial there
by the defense good job done by la tang
but now it's ovechkin shooting and it's
blocked off by
marc-andre fleury and cleared ahead
moving right in his vulcan on a
breakaway
[Applause]
we'll hit one hand mark andre fleury
with a couple terrific stops to save
the play by chris letang and an evgeny
malkin right between the wickets of
simeon varlamoff i'm sure fleury will
get an assist on this one what a move by
malkin it was a tough change for the
washington capitals in the second period
they have the long change they didn't
have enough defensemen on the ice after
that great save why marc-andre fleury
and that's why malcolm was in all along
what a play by the penguins of
marc-andre fleury
[Applause]